WE ARE OUT OF TIME.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
THE REPULSIVE DISGUSTING SCHIFF
SHOW CIRCUS IS OVER.
FINALLY, WE SEE THE LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL.
AT THIS HOUR, VERY GOOD SOURCES
ARE TELLING ME THAT THE
SCHUMER-SCHIFF SHAM SHOW IS
CIRCLING THE DRAIN.
CAN’T COME SOON ENOUGH.
IT APPEARS SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER, McCONNELL, NOW HAS THE
VOTES TO BLOCK FURTHER WITNESSES
AND THIS WHOLE POINTLESS CHARADE
COULD BE WRAPPED UP FRIDAY OR
SATURDAY OF THIS WEEK.
EARLIER TODAY, COLORADO SENATOR,
CORY GARDNER ANNOUNCED THAT HE
DIDN’T NEED TO HEAR FROM AN 18TH
WITNESS TO RENDER A VERDICT.
JOHN BOLTON IS NOW OFFICIALLY
OUT OF THE EQUATION BEING NEEDED
AS A WITNESS.
I’LL EXPLAIN IN A MINUTE.
THEY REPUBLIC DOMINIC NEED
JUST TO BE HONEST, IT COULD COME
LAMAR SIDE OF THE AISLE.
THERE IS NO HIGH ANXIETY INSIDE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ANY AGREEMENT WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO A PACKAGE DEAL.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE WILL TELL YOU
WHY THAT’S NO LONGER NECESSARY
IN A MINUTE.
SO WILL TWO KEY MEMBERS OF,
LET’S SAY THE THE BIDEN SYNDICAT
QUID PRO QUO JOE, ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
A BARE MINIMUM IS A SERIOUS
APPEARANCE OF IMPROPRIETY.
WE WENT THROUGH ALL THE LAWS
THAT WELL, SEEM TO FIT IN THIS
CASE.
THE PRESIDENT, REMEMBER, HAS A
SWORN CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO
FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE LAWS OF
THIS LAND AND THAT’S WHY HE WAS
RIGHTLY CONCERNED, NOT ONLY
ABOUT UKRAINE ENTER ELECTION
INTERFERENCE APART FROM A
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, WHICH
DEVIN NUNES WARNED ABOUT.
HE IS ALSO RIGHTLY CONCERNED
ABOUT QUID PRO QUO JOE AND NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT ELIZABETH WARREN
OR BERNIE SANDERS, WHO HAPPENS
TO BE LEADING IN BOTH IOWA AND
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
LET ME SUM IT UP FOR YOU ONE
MORE TIME.
THIS THING IS OVER.
IT’S FINISHED.
EVERYTHING ELSE WILL BE A NEAR
FORMALITY.
NOW, WE KNOW HOW THIS WILL E WIL
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE ACQUITTED,
AND THANKFULLY, IN 279 DAYS, WE
WILL HAVE AN ELECTION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE HAVE
HEARD FROM WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
THOUGHT WOULD BE THERE LATEST
STAR WITNESS MOMENTS AGO, THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT THESE
WORDS, "GAME OVER" ALONG
WITH THE WORDS, HE SENT OUT A VI
JOHN BOLTON, PRAISING THE
PRESIDENT’S PHONE CALL.
YES, THE ONE IN QUESTION, WITH
UKRAINE.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WILL BE NEEDING ZELINSKY.
HE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN TWICE.
HE CALLED TO CONGRATULATE
PRESIDENT ZELINSKY ON HIS
ELECTION AND HIS SUCCESS IN THE
PARLIAMENTARY ELECTION.
THEY WERE VERY WARM AND CORDIAL
CALLS.
WE WILL HOPE THAT THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO MEET IN WARSAW.
THE SUCCESS OF UKRAINE
MAINTAINING ITS FREEDOM, ITS
SYSTEM OF REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT, FREE MARKET ECONOMY
FREE OF A CROP CORRUPTION ARE HI
PRIORITIES HERE, OBVIOUSLY,
BAHA’I PRIORITIES FOR THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL.
>> Sean: SOUNDS ALMOST
VERBATIM.
THE PRESIDENT’S DESCRIPTION OF
THE CALL AND WHAT WE ALL READ
WITH THIS TRANSCRIPT.
DID YOU HEAR ANY DIRE WARNINGS
ABOUT MISCONDUCT OR ABUSE OF
POWER?
DID YOU HEAR ANY COMPLAINTS OR
DOMINIC AT ALL?
THE ANSWER IS NO.
NOW, THAT MEAN DEL MY BRINGS ME
TO MITT ROMNEY TONIGHT.
I THOUGHT THAT HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE BETTER CANDIDATE AND I
THINK WE WERE PROVEN RIGHT, IF
HE WON HIS ELECTION IN 2012.
I DEFENDED HIM AGAINST.
THEY CALLED HIM A MISOGYNIST.
THEY ACCUSED HIM OF ABUSING
ANIMALS AND EVEN CUTTING SOME
KID’S HAIR.
HE SAID LATER IN THE WEEK THAT
HE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM
JOHN BOLTON.
WELL, WE HAVE NOT HEARD
EVERYTHING WE NEED TO HEAR FROM
JOHN BOLTON IN HIS OWN WORDS AND
EVEN IF THE PRESIDENT PRIVATELY
SAID THAT HE WANTED UKRAINE TO
DO A OR B OR C FOR THE AID, HERE
ARE FOUR FACTS THAT HE REMINDS
US EVERY TIME.
THEY WILL NEVER CHANGE.
NO LINKAGE BETWEEN AID AND
INVESTIGATIONS DURING THE PHONE
CALL.
AID WAS NEVER MENTIONED DURING
THE PHONE CALL, BUT THE USUAL
CORRUPTION WAS BROUGHT UP.
THE PRESIDENT WAS CLEARLY
CONCERNED.
IT WAS TOP OF MIND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ZELINSKY
HAVE DENIED PRESSURE IN ANY
SHAPE, MATTER, AND FORM.
NO ONE IN UKRAINE EVEN KNEW
THERE WAS A TEMPORARY PAUSE ON
AID AT THE TIME OF THE CALL OR
LONG AFTER THE CALL, AND
UKRAINE, HERE’S THE IMPORTANT
PART, DID THEY DO ANYTHING?
DID THEY TAKE ANY ACTION?
DID THEY GET THE AID RELEASED?
NONE.
ZERO.
NOTHING.
DID THEY ANNOUNCE THEY WOULD DO
SOMETHING?
NOTHING.
THEY ANNOUNCE TO NOTHING NEVER,
EVER AND THEY STILL GOT THE
MONEY.
SO, EVEN IF THE PRESIDENT BOUGHT
IT, EVEN IF HE SAID IT, MAY BE
THINKING ABOUT IT, IT DOESN’T
MATTER.
IT’S WHAT HE DID.
SENATOR ROMNEY, I SAY TO YOU
TONIGHT, IT IS TIME FOR YOU TO
PUT ASIDE WHAT IS CLEARLY A
PERSONAL DISDAIN, DISLIKE FOR
THE PRESIDENT, AND YOU NEED TO
DO THIS FOR THE SAKE OF THE
COUNTRY, AND FRANKLY FOR YOUR
SWORN DUTIES OF THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES.
NOW, FORGET ABOUT YOUR OPINIONS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE IRRELEVANT.
YOU NEED THAT DOCUMENT RIGHT
THERE.
YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE AND DUTY AS
A SENATOR.
REMEMBER, THE HOUSE AND THE
CONSTITUTION HAS THE SOLE POWER
TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT.
NOW, THEY PRESENTED THEIR
PATHETIC WEAK CASE.
OKAY, NOW YOU ARE ASKING 16
HOURS WORTH OF QUESTIONS.
YOUR DUTY IS AS THE SOLE ROLE OF
THE SENATE IS TO RENDER A
VERDICT.
NOW, YOU JUST HEARD FROM
JOHN BOLTON.
KEEP IN MIND, SENATOR ROMNEY, I
KNOW YOU REPRESENT THE GREAT
STATE OF UTAH.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS SURVEY PUT
TOGETHER BY, HE IS ONE OF THE
FEW PEOPLE.
I’VE KNOWN MATT SINCE THE
NEWT GINGRICH POLLING YEARS.
IT’S ON VIDEO.
I’VE GOT A COPY.
DONALD TRUMP WAS GOING TO WIN.
NOT MANY POSTERS WERE SAYING
THIS PART 68%.
HE DID A POLL OF UTAH.
THEY WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACQUITTED.
64% OPPOSE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
PAIRED 60% WOULD BE LESS LIKELY
TO SUPPORT YOU IF YOU VOTED TO
KEEP THE CHARADE GOING ON CALL
WITNESSES.
BY THE WAY, THINK ABOUT ALL
THOSE DEMOCRATS THAT ARE ASKING
YOU TO TRUST THEM.
THINK ABOUT WHO IS BEGGING FOR
WITNESSES.
THERE HE IS.
THE COMPROMISED, IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE, CORRUPT, AND WE
ALL KNOW, CONGENITAL LIAR BY THE
NAME OF ADAM SCHIFF.
HOW COULD ANYONE IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE EVER TRUST WHAT IS
MERELY A PRETTY DESPICABLE
SOCIOPATH?
HIS HANDS HAVE BEEN ON FIRE FOR
THREE CONSECUTIVE YEARS.
HE LIED ABOUT RUSSIA, COLLUSION,
FISA, HE LIED ABOUT THE PHIS
APPLICATION AND THE UKRAINE
PHONE CALL.
HE LIED ABOUT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE EVEN LIED ABOUT THE
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WANT YOU TO DO ME A FAVOR,
THOUGH.
I WANT YOU TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION OF MITT ROMNEY.
>> DO ANY OF US HAVE ANY QUESTIO
THAT BARACK OBAMA WOULD BE
IMPEACHED FOR THAT KIND OF
MISCONDUCT?
THAT’S A PARALLEL HERE.
>> Sean: AND HE LIED IN HIS
REPORT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOW, WE KNOW, BECAUSE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT, THAT
HE LIED AND CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES TOLD THE TRUTH.
THE BULK OF THE INFORMATION WAS
THE DIRTY UNVERIFIABLE DOSSIER
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR.
THE ONLY AMERICAN WE KNOW ON
TAPE, THINKING HE’S TALKING TO A
RUSSIAN, COLLUDING TO GET DIRT
ON DONALD TRUMP TO USE AN
ELECTION.
WOULD YOU HAVE?
COMPROMISING MATERIALS.
REALLY?
WHAT ARE THEY?
DID VLADIMIR SEE THEM?
CAN WE HAVE THEM?
THAT WOULD BE ADAM SCHIFF.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T SAY,
BY THE WAY, IN THE TRANSCRIPT,
EVEN THOUGH, YEAH, SCHIFF HAD TO
MAKE THAT UP TOO APPEARED HE
DIDN’T SAY, DO ME A FAVOR.
HE SAID, DO US A FAVOR.
HE SAID, IN RELATION TO THE
UNITED STATES, AND OF COURSE, WE
HAVE THE UKRAINIAN COURT.
THEY BOTH DETERMINED THAT THERE
WAS ELECTION INTERFERENCE TO
HELP HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY CITED.
BY THE WAY, INTERFERENCE THAT WE
WERE ALL WORKED UP ABOUT FOR
THREE LONG YEARS.
IT TAKES 22 MINUTES TO READ IT.
NATURALLY, THAT WAS ONLY ONE OF
MANY LIVES TODAY FROM THE
CONGENITAL LIAR.
NOW, THIS IS PRETTY AMAZING.
ONE TRULY BIZARRE EXAMPLE FROM
EARLIER TODAY, YEP, THE
CONGENITAL LIAR, SCHIFF,
ACTUALLY DOUBLED DOWN ON A LIE
THAT HAS PREVIOUSLY EARNED HIM
FOUR PINOCCHIO’S FROM THE
LIBERAL "WASHINGTON POST"."
FOR A DEMOCRAT, THAT’S HARD TO
GET.
DESPITE THE MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE
THAT HE COMMUNICATED WITH THE
FAKE WHISTLE-BLOWER, WELL,
CONGENITAL LIAR STILL CLAIMING
HE HAD NO IDEA WITH THE PERSON
IS.
DO YOU BELIEVE HIM?
HE IS CONTRADICTED, BACK AND
FORTH AND BACK AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON’T KNOW
WHO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS.
I HAVEN’T MET THEM OR
COMMUNICATED WITH THEM IN ANY
WAY.
THE CONSPIRACY THEORY, WHICH I
THINK WAS OUTLINED EARLIER, THAT
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER CONCLUDED
WITH THE INTEL COMMITTEE STAFF
TO HATCH AN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
IS A COMPLETE AND TOTAL FICTION.
>> Sean: HE FIRST SAID THAT.
THEN, HE SAID, YEAH, THERE WAS
CONTACT WITH MY OFFICE.
NOW, HE SAYING IT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL FICTION
WHEN EVEN THE LIBERAL
"WASHINGTON POST" WILL GIVE A
DEMOCRAT FOUR PINOCCHIO’S,
BECAUSE HE’S LYING.
IF THE CONGENITAL LIAR IS NOT
GOING TO HIDE, THEN WHY DID HE
REFUSE TO CALL THE HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER IN FOR TESTIMONY,
WHICH HE ORIGINALLY PROMISED TO
DO?
WHY DID HE ADMIT THERE WAS
CONTACT WITH HIS STAFF, WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER?
AND THIS WAS A WITCH HUNT THAT
HAS BEEN LED TOTALLY COMPLETELY
BY HIM, A DERANGED LIAR, AND ALL
HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS THAT HATE
TRUMP EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
THERE IS NOTHING LEGITIMATE
ABOUT THE CHARADE.
THERE NEVER HAS BEEN.
YOU’VE GOT SCHIFF,.
ZERO DUE PROCESS.
THE ACCUSATIONS ARE UNTRUE.
TODAY, THE PRESIDENT’S LEGAL
TEAM BEAT THE LIVING OVER THE
DEMOCRATS.
THAT WOULD BE ACQUITTAL.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> HIS WORDS WOULD BE WRONG IF
THE FBI OR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WAS STARTING A POLITICAL
INVESTIGATION OF SOMEONE’S
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
I’M THINKING TO MYSELF, BUT
ISN’T THAT EXAM WHO WOULD
HAPPEN?
MULTIPLE WITNESSES WHO WERE
CALLED IN THE HOUSE BY THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS TESTIFIED THAT THE
UNITED STATES POLICY TOWARDS
UKRAINE GOT STRONGER UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, IN PART,
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THAT LETHAL
AID.
>> THE ISSUE IS NOT WHETHER A
CRIME WAS.
THE ANSWER FROM THE HISTORY IS
CLEARLY UNEQUIVOCALLY NO.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, THE
QUESTION AND ANSWER PERIOD WERE
CONTINUING TO MONITOR.
WE WILL PUT IT UP ON THE SIDE OF
YOUR SCREEN HERE YOU CAN TAKE A
LOOK AND IF ANYTHING COMPELLING
COMES UP, WE WILL BRING IT TO
LIVE WHILE THE PRESIDENT’S TEAM
PUTS FORWARD A SERIOUS CASE.
TOP DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO PLAY
THEIR POLITICAL GAMES.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS ALL THEY
HAVE DONE FOR THREE YEARS.
NOT A SINGLE THING FOR THE WE
THE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PUBLIC
SERVANTS.
PELOSI’S FRIEND, CHUCK SCHUMER.
HE TOOK A MILLION DOLLARS FROM
RUSSIA AND TRIED TO HIDE IT,
ANOTHER VIOLATION.
HE BRIEFLY BECAME A FAR LEFT
HERO BECAUSE OF HIS ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST TRUMP.
HE IS ON BAIL FOR THE VIOLATIONS
OF FINANCING AND TRYING TO HIDE
THE BILLION DOLLAR PAYMENT FROM
OF ALL COUNTRIES, RUSSIA.
HE COULDN’T GET IN, BECAUSE HE’S
WEARING AN ELECTRONIC ANKLE
BRACELET.
THIS IS THEIR STAR WITNESS.
ADAM SCHIFF SAYS, BELIEVE HIM,
BUT ADAM HUNTER DID NOTHING.
THEY ARE HURTING THE COUNTRY AND
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HIS LAWYER CALLED US UP AND
ASKED FOR TICKETS LIKE MANY
NEW YORK CONSTITUENTS.
I SAID, YOU CAN GET TICKETS.
WE GIVE THEM OUT TO THE
NEW YORKERS WHO HAVE ASKED.
I’M NOT SURE HE WOULD BE ALLOWED
IN BECAUSE OF THE ELECTRONICS
AROUND HIS ANKLE.
>> Sean: MANY WELL-INDICTED
NEW YORKERS WITH ANKLE
BRACELETS, THEY ALL WANT TO GO.
YOU KNOW THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
BFFs, AND THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE ALL PLAYING
THESE POLITICAL GAMES.
I GUESS THEY THINK WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE STUPID.
THEY CLEARLY DON’T LIKE THE WAY
WE VOTE.
THEY SEEM TO HATE OUR WAY OF
LIFE.
THEY SEEM TO HATE OUR VALUES.
THEY SEEM TO HATE OUR CHOICE FOR
PRESIDENT.
WE’VE BEEN CALLED DEPLORABLE
WALMART SHOPPING JUMPERS.
THEY THINK IT’S A BAD THING THAT
WE ARE ANGRY AND THAT WE ARE
BITTER AND WE CLING TO GOD.
OKAY, I’M GUILTY.
I WANT TO CLING TO GOD, OUR
CONSTITUTION, OUR BIBLES, AND I
BELIEVE IN MY FAITH.
I DO.
I’M GUILTY.
I BELIEVE IN GOD.
YEP.
OKAY.
GUILTY.
PERFECT ENCAPSULATION.
THIS IS A TALE NOW OF TWO
AMERICANS.
ON THE ONE SIDE, YEAH, NOTHING
BUT 24/7 EIGHT, COME PUSHING
NOTHING, NEVER ENDING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, HOAXES, LIES,
WITCH HUNTS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, YOU’VE GOT A
PRESIDENT, KEEPING EVERY PROMISE
HE IS MADE, A SUCCESSFUL AGENDA,
UNPRECEDENTED SUCCESS
ECONOMICALLY AND FOREIGN POLICY,
REAL TANGIBLE RESULTS.
WE PUT TOGETHER A VIDEO THAT
PERFECTLY EXEMPLIFIES THIS
CRITICAL MOMENT IN TIME.
TWO AMERICANSTO AMERICANS, THIS
FOR GRABS IN 279 DAYS.
YOU WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY
AND YOU CAN TO SHOCK THE WORLD
AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE CREATED 7 MILLION NEW
JOBS.
THE AVERAGE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
UNDER MY ADMINISTRATION IS LOWER
THAN ANY PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
LISTEN TO THIS ONE, IN
UNITED STATES HISTORY
HISTORY.
>> TRUMP IS THE SMART ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ARE YOU AN ELITIST WITH YOUR
GEOGRAPHY AND YOUR MAPS?
>> IF YOU VOTE FOR TRUMP, YOU
ARE THE BAD GUY.
>> WE ALSO SIGNED A FANTASTIC
NEW TRADE AGREEMENT WITH CHINA.
>> THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
FACTS.
THEY DON’T KNOW ABOUT THE FACTS.
>> WE HAVE FULLY REBUILT THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY.
>> YOU COULD PUT HALF OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S INTO WHAT I CALL THE
BASKET OF DEPLORABLES.
>> AMERICA IS WINNING AGAIN AND
AMERICA IS THRIVING AGAIN LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
>> LET’S SEE, WE CAN ADD TO
THAT, YEP, THE NUMBER ONE
STATE-SPONSORED TERROR, THEIR
LEADER, SOLEIMANI, DEAD.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT SINCE
1969.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH AND IMPLEMENT,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WOW.
WE ARE AT A CRITICAL POINT.
279 DAYS.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHOCK
THE ESTABLISHMENT WORLD AGAIN.